in all my years in uniform
i haven't known
such a clear threat to the principles of
sovereignty and democracy
and the freedom to live without fear of
violence as the brutal aggression of
president putin
and his expansionist ambitions
i believe we're living through a history
a period of history as profound as the
one our forebears did 80 years ago and
now as then our choices will have a
disproportionate effect on the future
this is our 1937 moment
we're not at war
but we must act rapidly so that we
aren't drawn into one through a failure
to contain territorial expansion
so surely it's beholden on each of us to
ensure that we never find ourselves
asking that futile question
should we have done more
i'll do everything in my power to ensure
that the british army plays its part in
averting war
i will have an answer to my
grandchildren should they ever ask what
i did in 2022
so we have agency to prevent war now
but only if we take a new approach
now these are extraordinary times
so i won't take the usual approach of a
new cgs to this event
it will not be the traditional
tour of the horizon covering the full
breadth of army business
i'll concentrate on one area alone how i
intend to mobilize the british army our
regulars
our reservists and our civilians to
deter russian aggression
to prevent war
now we're already a busy army but
today's about mobilization and to
mobilize effectively we will need to
suppress
our additive culture and to guard
against the tyranny of and we can't do
everything well
and some things are going to have to
stop it will mean ruthless
prioritization
so from now the army will have a
singular focus to mobilize to meet
today's threat and thereby prevent war
in europe
this is not the rush to war at the speed
of the railway timetables of 1914
it is instead an acceleration of the
most important parts
of future soldiers bold modernization
agenda
a move to a positional strategy
an increased focus on readiness and
combined arms training
and a broader institutional renewal that
creates the culture required to win if
called upon
this process we'll give it a name
operation mobilize will be the army's
primary focus over the coming years
so why do we need to mobilize
well under the leadership of the prime
minister
and the defense secretary the united
kingdom has risen to meet russia's
aggression
defence has worked at a phenomenal pace
to bring together a coalition of
partners to provide material
intelligence and training to sustain
ukraine in its fight against the russian
invaders
our bilateral relationship with kiev has
gone from strength to strength
this year alone we have supplied nine
and a half thousand anti-tank missiles
of which over five thousand were endless
we've already provided uk-based training
for 650 armed forces of ukraine soldiers
and in the coming months the british
army will deliver battle winning skills
to a further ten thousand it's just
starting
the upcoming madrid summit tomorrow
is a timely opportunity to demonstrate
our leadership in nato and our enduring
commitment to our allies
mobilizing the army to prevent war is as
tangible and concrete an act of
leadership as i can offer
the uk will lead by example
now it's dangerous to assume that
ukraine is a limited conflict
one of its obvious lessons is that
putin's calculations don't always follow
our own logic
it's also worth remembering that
historically russia often starts wars
badly and because russia wages war at
the strategic
and not the tactical level its depth and
resilience means it can suffer any
number of campaigns battles and
engagements lost
and yet regenerate and still ultimately
prevail
history has also shown us
that armies that have tasted defeat
learn more quickly
and while russia's conventional
capability will be much reduced for a
time at least
putin's declared intent
recently to restore the lands of
historic russia
makes any respite temporary
and the threat will become even more
acute
we don't know
how the war in ukraine will end but in
most scenarios russia will be an even
greater threat to european security
after ukraine than it was before
the russian invasion has reminded us of
that time honored maxim that if you want
to avert conflict you better be prepared
to fight
so this is the challenge
that i will address through mobilization
and to make it crystal clear that means
focusing on winning the war working with
these allies against this threat in this
location and we'll see the first orders
issued in madrid tomorrow
now this threat's also materialized at a
time when the world is already looking
less secure the viewpoint set out
clearly in last year's integrated review
and defense command paper
in meeting a revanchist russia we can't
be guilty of myopically chasing the ball
defense cannot ignore the exponential
rise and chronic challenge of china
not just within the south china sea but
through sub-threshold activities across
the globe
beijing will be watching our response to
moscow's actions carefully
but ceding more territory to putin could
prove a fatal blow to the principle of
national sovereignty that has
underpinned the international order
since 1945
and we can't allow nato states
to live with the grim reality
of the human cost of occupation that we
see in front of us
now given the commitments of the united
states in asia during the 20s and the
30s
i believe that the burden for
conventional deterrence in europe will
fall increasingly to european members of
nato and the jeff
and this is right in my view taking up
the burden in europe means we can free
more u.s resources to ensure that our
values and interests are protected in
the indo-pacific
and we're not alone in facing this
reality
looking out at you here today i'm
reassured by the number of allies and
partners i see before me
the faces of friends from previous
campaigns where we've shared hardship
and laughter failures and victories
we've shed blood together
we remember those we left behind
and it's this our willingness to shed
blood
to protect common values and each
other's territory that will see us
prevail
so how are we going to mobilize
well article 5 remains the cornerstone
of our national security it makes it a
critical national interest
the conflict in ukraine or held i think
a paradigm shift in how nato delivers
collective deterrence from a doctrine of
reacting to crises to one of deterring
them
and this principle is at the heart of
opmobilize russia knowing that they
cannot gain a quick localized victory
but in any circumstances and in any time
frame they will lose if they pick a
fight with nato
deterrence demands all the tools of
statecraft underpinned by soldiers
sailors aviators and civil servants
operating across all five operational
domains
it requires forces across defense that
are modernized relevant and harness the
potential of the fourth industrial
revolution effective deterrence also
means communicating clearly so we
maximize deterrent effects without
increasing the risk of mobilization
but when faced with an adversary such as
mr putin with the campaigns of peter the
great as his reference point
the war in ukraine
also reminds us of the utility
of land power
it takes an army to hold and regain
territory and defend the people who live
there it takes an army to deter
and this army the british army will play
its part alongside our allies
and in ukraine we've seen the
limitations of deterrence by punishment
it's reinforced the importance of
deterrence through denial
we must stop russia seizing territory
rather than expecting to respond to a
land grab with the delayed
counter-offensive
to succeed the british army in
conjunction with our nato allies and
partners must be in place or as
especially high readiness ideally a mix
of both
tripwires
aren't enough
if we fail to deter
there are no good choices given the cost
of a potential counter-attack and the
associated nuclear threat
we must therefore meet strength with
strength from the outset and be
unequivocally prepared to fight for nato
territory
now if this battle came
we would likely be outnumbered at the
point of attack
and fighting like hell
standoff air maritime or cyber fires are
unlikely to dominate on their own
land will still be the decisive domain
and though i bow to no one
in my advocacy for the need for
game-changing digital transformation to
put it bluntly you can't cyber your way
across a river
no single platform capability or tactic
will unlock the problem
success will be determined by combined
arms and multi-domain competence and
mass
ukraine has also shown
that engaging with our adversaries and
training assisting and reassuring our
partners
is high payoff activity
future soldiers new ranger regiment on
the ground in ukraine before the
invasion and the new security force
assistance brigade are well set for this
with the right partner and in the right
conditions
persistent engagement and capacity
building can be really effective
operational orbital has made a key
contribution to preparing the armed
forces of ukraine for this fight and it
continues to expand exponentially
and we should be wary of russia's malign
activities further afield so our global
hubs including kenya and oman will still
play a vital role as we seek to mobilize
to meet aggression in europe allowing us
to help our partners there secure
strategic advantage
elsewhere in the world
this is the war that we are mobilizing
to prevent
by preparing to win with our nato and
jeff partners
against the russian threat
in eastern and northern europe
and in doing so it's my hope that we
never have to fight it
so what does this mean for the army well
my predecessor and my friend general sir
mark carlton smith laid the foundations
for the most ambitious transformation
of the british army in a generation
future soldier we i owe him a great debt
the government has also generously
committed 41 billion to army equipment
over the next decade
but as we face a new reality a race to
mobilize
we must be honest with ourselves about
future soldiers timelines
capability gaps and risks
and now our own diminished stockpiles as
a result of gifting in kind to the brave
soldiers of the armed forces of ukraine
so we shouldn't be afraid of necessary
heresies
defense is only as strong as its weakest
domain
and technology doesn't eliminate the
relevance of combat mass
so to mobilize the army
i'm going to drive activity across four
focused lines of effort
first and most importantly boosting
readiness
nato needs high reading forces that can
deploy at short notice for the
collective defense of alliance members
deterring russia means more of the army
ready more of the time
and ready for high-intensity war in
europe
so we'll pick up the pace of combined
arms training and major on urban combat
we'll rebuild our stockpiles and review
the deployability of our vehicle fleets
and having seen its limitations
firsthand as commander field army
i think we need to ask ourselves where
the whole fleet management is the right
model given the scale of the threat that
we face
the time has come to be frank about our
ability to fight if called upon
second will accelerate the modernization
outlined in future soldier
nato needs technologically advanced
modern armies able to deploy at speed
and fight together
they must be able to integrate effects
across the domains
all stitched together by sophisticated
and robust command
control and communication network
we'll seek to speed up the delivery of
plan new equipments
including long-range fires attack
aviation persistent surveillance and
target acquisition
expeditionary logistic enablers
ground-based air defense
protective mobility
and the technologies that will prove
pivotal to our digital ambition cis and
electronic warfare
most importantly this will start now and
not at some ill defined point in the
future
third
we'll rethink how we fight
we've been watching the war in ukraine
closely and we're already learning and
adapting not least to the help of rusa
many of the lessons are not new but they
are now applied
so we'll double down on combined arms
maneuver especially in the deep battle
and we'll devise a new doctrine rooted
in geography integrated with nato's war
plans and specific enough to drive
focused relevant investment and inspire
the imagination of our people to fight
and win if called upon
and fourth i am prepared to look again
at the structure of our army if we judge
the revised structures will make the
army better prepared to fight in europe
then we'll follow monty's advice and do
something else
now of course adapting structures has
implications for the size of the army
and i know that there will be questions
on army numbers lock loaded and ready to
fire from the audience
put simply
the threat has changed and as the threat
changes will change with it
my job is to build the best army
possible ready to integrate with fellow
services and strategic command and ready
to fight alongside our allies
nonetheless it would be perverse if the
cgs was advocating reducing the size of
the army as a land war rages in europe
and putin's territorial ambitions extend
into the rest of the decade
and beyond ukraine
importantly the four mechanisms i've
used to illustrate how the army will
mobilize will all be initiated from the
line of march this means now
rather than some distant undefined point
in the future
and not mobilize is as much about people
as it is about training and hardware
the last 125 days of conflict in ukraine
have shown us
if we needed showing the enduring nature
of war it's violent and human nature and
its timeless interplay of friction and
chance
it's reminded us all that war
fundamentally remains a clash of wills
russia's so-called special military
operation
has shown that while moscow may have
invested in some of the most modernized
land technology in the world
it lacked the will to fight
when faced with a tenacious ukrainian
defense
let down by its leaders
we've seen the moral decay of the
russian army play out in front of us
the fighting spirit of our people is the
army's greatest single greatest
responsibility
the moral component of fighting power
matters
to succeed in mobilizing we've got to
ensure that we engender the culture and
the behavior required to forge and
cohere a confident and winning team and
in my 37 years experience i've learned
that trust increases tempo
so i'm fully behind the teamwork
initiative
set up by my predecessor
it's not wake-ism nor in any way a
lessening of standards at a time when
the british army must be prepared to
engage in warfare at its most violent
to put it simply you don't need to be
lavish to be lethal and in a scrap you
have to truly trust those on your left
and right
and when the british army has been faced
with any challenge during its long
history it's always been the ingenuity
of our people that have seen us through
i know there will be an opportunity cost
to mobilizing
and will continually review and balance
our priorities to meet the emerging
threats
but mobilization also requires us to cut
down
that which slows us down
so i want you all i'm talking to the
army here
to identify those areas of our process
and bureaucracy that take up your time
like any public institution we've
accumulated some barnacles that slow us
down
but we're not just any institution
so it's time to strip them back
mobilization is not just an internal
focus and we must take industry with us
and have the right relationships with
our enabling agents to deliver and
quicken the ambitious modernization
targets we've set ourselves
i'll use the next few months to engage
personally with you our industry
partners and encourage you to use the
framework offered by the new land
industrial strategy to make the army
more lethal
and more effective with better equipment
in the hands of our soldiers at best
speed
we cannot be lighting the factory
furnaces across the nation on the eve of
war this effort must start now if we
want to prevent war from happening
now by nayi i think i'd be naive if i
ignored the fact that the army's
platform procurement
has not been a smooth journey during the
last decade we have the humility to
learn the lessons from where it's gone
wrong and the confidence to engage with
industry
to generate the mutual trust required to
get the very latest technology
for the best value for money
and we should also be a little bit
bolder in celebrating our successes
ah 64 echo is flying now
the first boxer will be in service in
2023
the first challenger three arrives in
2024
and the skysaber air defense system was
deployed and operating in poland only
weeks after entering service
so this speech forms my first order of
the day
mobilization is now the main effort
we're mobilizing the army to help
prevent war in europe by ready by by
being ready to fight and win alongside
our nato allies and partners
it'll be hard work
a generational effort and i expect all
ranks to get ready train hard and engage
we must be practical and cut through
unnecessary bureaucracy
be prepared to de-prioritize where
activity isn't mission critical
honestly highlight risks where we
identify them
and a full avoid falling victim to the
seidu gap
or the lure of institutional panaceas
conscious of the advice of the late
great john le carre that whitehall
panaceas often simply go out with a
whimper leaving behind the familiar
english model
i expect this change to be command led
and that includes all commanders from
the general in maine building to the
unlance corporal in the barrack room
from the reservist officer on a weekend
exercise to the civil servant in army
headquarters
and as we mobilize
i echo the words of general montgomery
to his team in the dust of the north
african desert in 1942.
we must have confidence in one another
as the new cgs
i have confidence in each and every one
of you
and i'm proud to stand among you
and my final message to you is this
this is the moment to defend the
democratic values that define us
this is the moment to help our brave
ukrainian allies in their galaxy
struggle
this is the moment we stand with our
friends and partners to maintain peace
throughout the rest of europe this is
our moment
caesar
chief of the general staff general sir
patrick sanders speaking there at roof c
in his uh first formal address in his
new role tamara is here with us um some
stark warnings there but he says we're
ready for the scrap indeed he's just
taken on the job this month and what a
powerful warning that the invasion of
ukraine at the end of february is a
moment like 1937 pat sir patrick says
this was this is similar russian
aggression he says is similar to the
run-up to nazi germany's invasions of
other european countries and we need to
be ready for it he says the british army
and other western armies need to be in a
better state not necessarily to provoke
a war but to prevent one and he says
that he hopes that our forces won't have
to fight in northern and eastern europe
not in ukraine of course but on in nato
countries and but he says that this is a
real possibility and at the moment our
armed forces are not in the right state
to do so we need to be in a higher state
of readiness we probably need more
soldiers he said he expected to be asked
about that he said it would be perverse
to cut the number indeed to to have
further cuts which are expected to we're
expected to come and i expect he'll also
be asked about um the defense secretary
wanting to increase spending on the
armed forces
after this spending period which ends in
2024 because of course he sees the
russian threat continuing for many years
to come we know that nato they're
meeting in madrid
today they are already calling they're
already saying they're going to have a
rapid response force of 300 000 troops
ready to go in eastern europe he says
the uk needs to be ready and he said
that although it is very important that
we concentrate on new technology and
digital technology he said pretty
bluntly you can't cyber your way across
a river this battle is going to be a
land battle and therefore the uk army
needs to focus on that he talked about
ruthless prioritization to meet the
current threat this is what he sees as
the current threat it's like 1937. he
says it's also a bit like the 18th
century because vladimir putin he says
sees himself as a latter day peter the
great this is the sort of battle we face
and he says the army needs to be ready
for it